louisiana thanks so much for joining us
you've achieved a big victory uh in the
courts in germany and the government has
responded
quickly by changing their targets are
you satisfied with their new commitments
no i think that wouldn't be appropriate
um
i mean after all this isn't about what
satisfies me or anyone else but this is
about governments aligning the climate
policies to the science and to paris
and the court in germany ruled that the
government needs to listen to the
science and
you know stick to the paris agreement
because it didn't do so in the past and
now
they did agree in fact on higher targets
but they're still
in line with paris so of course we're
going to keep fighting here
so what more immediate actions do you
want to see from the government
well there is a tendencies these days to
replace climate action
with setting climate targets but targets
cannot replace action
so what the government does and i think
this accounts for quite a few countries
is that they set even higher targets you
know again and again again
while in the present they you know
block actions that would allow them to
reach those targets in the first place
so what we need is government acting
here and now to effectively and
sustainably and just
reduce emissions so that any kind of
target can be reached then of course we
need to
you know on in the long run and adjust
ourselves to what is needed for 1.5
well yes and the targets they've set
some people say are very ambitious so
what kind of action is needed
what measures need to happen to try and
make those reductions
well of course in general that is up to
scientists
and you know the the expert the
scientists for future for instance
to advise on but what is kind of crystal
clear right now is that as long as the
german government is sticking to a coal
exit by 2038
something is going wrong some of the
biggest
sources of co2 in europe are based in
germany in fact six of them
are based in germany this is our
co-power plants which are wrecking the
climate and which co
which could go off the network um much
sooner than 2038 that's what experts
agree on widely
then there is a gas pipeline not stream
two which you know germany is
currently finishing right now i mean a
new gas pipeline of that dimension in
2021
that's simply absurd and i mean there
are a number of other things come you
know about
new roads being built um about the
government actually preventing new
investments and renewables and
all those things when you look at them
closely they just don't add up
and it's good and nice to have you know
big speeches about
everyone wanting to do paris agreement
action together
but if you look closely and molecules
don't lie it doesn't work out
so when we're talking about targets then
the uk government has also set ambitious
targets they're going to be hosting
the climate summit cop 26 later this
year so do you think they're doing the
right thing and
leading the way and and showing the way
for the rest of the world
well i think it's not up to me to um to
judge the uk
climate policies but when what i've
heard from experts in the uk of course
is that there are plenty of things that
um don't add up either i mean it's
um it's a great victory that a new
co-project was
um prevented um from like by activists
and others
and but i feel you know right now when
we look at it and i mean there are
plenty of
um reports proving that um especially
those very emission intensive countries
in the global north
who not just have an emission
responsibility but also a huge
historical responsibility
they are not keeping up to to what you
know they're in charge of right now
and i do very much wonder you know who
else is there who are we expecting to
to rise up first if it isn't those who
have caused the climate christ in the
first place
and are now very well equipped and rich
enough and industrialized enough
to you know get rid of fossil fuels as
soon as possible
and not just you know when it kind of
works out politically
the changes that have happened in
germany have come about because
you went to court and you won so is
litigation the best way to make changes
rather than street activism
no i wouldn't um i wouldn't put this in
kind of some kind of hierarchy here
um what we see is that we need to try
everything
we can and so i would rather understand
this as a huge puzzle and you know
litigation is one
piece of that puzzle and street action
and climate action civil disobedience
and working inside institutions that's
that are different puzzles and
you know ideally eventually they come up
together and they add up
and they produce that kind of pressure
and awareness that we so desperately
need
i mean i feel you know this this
litigation victory was huge
but we cannot solve the climate crisis
court case by court case
simply because you know these court um
systems work very very slowly it took
over in a year for the court to decide
that a climate target that was decided
in 2019
isn't ambitious enough so i feel you
know we need to also understand that
these climate
cases these litigation cases they can
provide a foundation for our work as
activists to then come back to that and
actually demand
our rights to be turned into politics
because that's actually what the court
said is we have a fundamental right to
climate justice
and that is big but we know that we're
not getting anything for free here we're
gonna fight for it we have to fight for
it
we have to demand that the government
actually sticks to what the court
decided
and you are fighting on different fronts
aren't you because as well as the court
case you've been
helping organise the school strikes in
germany
how did you first get started in that
what first motivated you to get involved
well you know i i never planned to
become a climate activist
and simply because i thought that
government in the 21st century
would get things done and i mean the
science is there
and we see what the climate crisis does
today and i thought you know there were
people who are aware of all that and
would sort things out
you know by the end of the day and when
i found out a couple of years after the
power segment was signed
what was happening around the world and
also in germany how governments were
just failing so badly to stick what they
themselves committed
to do i got i got very irritated and
angry
and uh by i don't know by um coincidence
or so
i ended up at the climate conference in
poland in 2018
and i ran into greta juneberg and
apparently she was the only one who
acted like we were in a crisis
on this u.n climate conference and so i
went back home and was like okay i think
i think when you do something and i
think
i need to do something and you know i i
felt it was
it was something way out at my comfort
zone to start
climate activism on the streets and to
start organizing i thought you know
systems would just
work out and eventually solve those
problems
and it was a very you know terrifying
experience to see
that this might not happen and we will
have to start taking ourselves seriously
here and do whatever we can
and do you think it's made a difference
are opinions changing
in germany about climate change do you
think
well again i think there's not what
about what i think or so but what we see
is that
studies are proving that people are
definitely
um you know and becoming much more aware
and what
the climate crisis does today that it
exists today
and that things need to change much
quicker otherwise the climate
crisis will do those changes for us and
and what we also see of course we are
just you know five months and before a
major election year the general election
in germany is happening soon
and we see that the the vibes around the
climate crisis are
unprecedented you know there are
majorities in this country who
say that they will go and vote in the
favor of the climate that is i think
that is
pretty big but again that is one part of
the puzzle piece
and yet what we still need is this kind
of action
the kind of effective emission reduction
and obviously people everywhere
starting to you know become part of the
solution well yes and you say
talk about the election as you say it's
a few months away but the green party
is doing well in the polls isn't it do
you think that a chancellor from de
gruner is realistic
um well we never had any kind of
election like this where actually you
know
there were the greens you know putting
forward a chance la canada
um by the end of the day this isn't up
to a particular chancellor no matter
from which party but this is about
a broad consensus that we need on 1.5
degree politics and this needs to be you
know
um bipartisan we need parties in the
entire democratic spectrum in germany to
understand that this isn't question
if we do climate actions or what kind of
climate action we do
that is where we need to have the debate
and this one election won't solve the
you know the climate action that is
needed in germany
ideally we end up with a election result
that can
again provide a foundation for further
work that needs to be done
and that is not a single person that
will change it but it's
rather the general the the vibe the um
attention on the issue and how far would
you take your environmental fight would
you take it into politics would you run
for office
well i i kind of i think i decided i
want to do everything i can
to to fight for climate justice wherever
this is most effective and
what we see right now is that activism
any kind of activism can change
everything and so as an activist i see
that
you know this is needed much more maybe
at some point we get to a stage where i
feel okay
my work as an activist on the street and
the movement
isn't as needed anymore maybe as it
could be somewhere else and then
we need to chat again but you know if
you would have asked me five years ago
what would you do in five years i would
have never imagined to to to do what i
do right now
so i've grown very conscious about
making any assumptions about my future
keeping your options open
well yes that as well okay louisa nobel
really good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed thank you